hi I'm Erik Bosse in the Neuse addition
to the lego movie universe lego movie to
the second part just released a trailer
the movie comes out in February 2019 and
I was a big fan of the first lego movie
and Lego Batman just a crazy amount of
attention to detail and memories about
my best friend's let's go through this
trailer shot-for-shot and point out all
the little mystical details about lego
movie - and potential spoiler warning in
case any of my predictions end up being
too on-the-nose and that bugs you it
happens in time time here let's get
started a lifetime has passed since the
horrific events of Taco Tuesday our
lives descended into chaos okay in this
opening section wyldstyle aka Lucy lays
out the aftermath of the horrific events
of Taco Tuesday she's referring to the
ending of the first movie when Will
Ferrell's dad character agrees to let
his son play with his lego set now that
I'm letting you come down here and play
guess who else gets to come down here
and play your sister we also get a quick
flash back to the planet Duplo attack
with a callback to the character series
scratching post and her mini cats
fleeing in terror and now we see this
post-apocalyptic world after the aliens
a planet DUPLO laid waste at bricksburg
I'm guessing the little sister wrecks
the set and the tab in the Sun just
stopped bothering to clean it up bricks
Berg's new design is a clear reference
to George Miller's Mad Max movies
specifically the recent fury road with
wild style as furiosa and everyone with
their tricked-out cars and motorcycles
and she's standing on the torch of the
ruins of the Statue of Liberty
that's a nod to another post-apocalyptic
movie the original Planet of the Apes
let's move on this new life has
toughened
two copies please one black one with
just a touch of cream in 25 sugars
okay here we see more of the Mad Max
fury road design in the coffee shop and
if you look closely as they shatter
their mugs you can see the animators
continued including the Lego piece
number stamp on the shards all these
guys have different weapons this - tis a
bat with nails sticking out of it and
then we see Emmet voiced by Chris Pratt
totally unchanged fun detail here the
barista Larry is the same barista from
the first movie but now he's been fury
roaded he wears a crazy mask that's kind
of similar the one worn by immortan joe
and unlike the copies seen in the first
movie where the coffee was over priced
at $37 a cup notice how now everything
costs nothing presumably because in this
post apocalypse currency has been
eliminated
moving on well most of us okay outside
the music shifts to this tween dream
remix of everything is awesome and it
also has a pop Sonova remix and an
electro crunk remix this version is by
comedy music duo Garfunkel and Oates
Kate Micucci actually is voiced a lot of
lego movie characters including Clayface
in Lego Batman and again I love the
visual details here that coffee shops
name is copy unchained changed from
these Starbucks s cat the coffee chain
in the first movie and this dude on the
right appears to have a rig with a
punching bag dangling in front of him so
we can just jab it over and over and
when Emmet greets these sewer babies
notice the weapon that the last one is
carrying these are Wolverine claws for
the Wolverine Lego set onto the next
section and it you've gotta stop
pretending everything is awesome
it isn't yeah I get it and that's why
I've cultivated a totally card edge side
that's super tough and now obviously
this isn't a shooting star it is tea
time after all
Emmet has stitched an E and L forever
pillow for their front porch swing let's
move on
Oh what is it up to that beat is pretty
fresh
here we see this new alien spaceship
which looks a lot like The probe's
different colored one maybe from heroes
of the storm and the music coming from
it is intergalactic by the Beastie Boys
the music video of which has a similar
invasion from outer space sci-fi theme
that this movie appears to have moving
on and in this section the ship fires
this heart bomb at the bricksburg sign
suggesting these newcomers could be from
the same planet DUPLO that the first
invaders were maybe the sister character
has come back to this dusty Lego set for
more toys that she wants to bring back
to her room and the voice of this heart
bomb is adorable its voice kind of
sounds like the character catbug from
bravest warriors a cartoon hangover that
was likely the same voice actor worked
on lego movie - movie not
[Music]
it's like it knows our every move weird
right what okay as they try to escape
Emmitt make sure to save his longtime
buddy planty who also returns from the
first movie and before this very funny
blinker gag there are a couple more cool
animation details the car jumps a ramp
made from a billboard probably when I
used to say everything is awesome and
one of the heart bombs that the ship
fires at them has a visible thumbprint
on it and if these pieces were from my
lego said there would be a frustrated
bright mark on it because sometimes just
won't come apart moving on I did the
warrior search so you fought masterbuilt
and hit but and then the hapless male
was the leader here well in this section
we meet the new character apparently
named sweet mayhem she's voiced by
actress Stephanie Beatriz from Brooklyn
nine-nine and she beats the old gang
from the first movie including Batman
and princess unikitty Benny the space
man and metal beard
actress Tiffany Haddish will also be
voicing a new character the
shape-shifting queen whatever I'm 1 Navy
which is an amazing name I'm assuming we
will see her in future trailers but for
now let's move on
here while style Luci strings off
Batman's cable to dodge some stickers
from sweet mayhem one of them is a
mustache sticker that lands fright on
Batman's face
hopefully the mustache removal CGI
technology is advanced since justice
league and it appears that mayhem
kidnapped all the main characters except
Emmett maybe the idea is the sister
looted only the Lego figure she found
awesome enough to take back to her room
leaving Emmett to feel less on to the
next section hang on to your fronds plan
e we're going to save Lucy and all of
the other people who were captured
[Music]
and here Emmett blasts off with plan T
to save Lucy and the others big thing
worth pointing out here is notice how
his ship is actually a modified version
of his house that we saw earlier very
cool
and after the title we come to the final
part for the satisfaction of wooing miss
yes
the sis star system makes it pretty
clear where this galaxy is in the SIS
stars bedroom and you can actually see
some of those tech gum wall stars in the
background now descriptions of this
movie have hinted at one of these
planets being an all musical planet
which makes sense because if Chris Pratt
is gonna be part of a movie you know
there's gonna be dancing a question for
you guys do you think Batman should
really be the star of this movie I mean
let's be honest he stole the show in the
first movie and that's why he got his
own movie I just could have used a bit
more of him in this trailer comment down
below with your thoughts or tweet me
directly at us and follow new rockstars
on Twitter for updates on our videos
like this video share it around and
subscribe the new rock stars for all of
our breakdowns and it's a stuff you love
we got videos about the Pixar movies and
Rick and Morty just take a look around
you might find something you like thanks
for watching bye
[Music]